Traduttore: Cecilia Bernabeni
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buongiorno a tutti.
Come ha già detto il presentatore,
mi chiamo Fabrizio Lori.
Vedo davanti a me una serie, la A.
E questa è una lettera
che io ho amato tantissimo.
Però l'ho anche odiata,
e adesso cerco di spiegarvi perché.
Era il lontano 2004/2005,
parliamo di quasi 15 anni fa,
e i dirigenti del Mantova di allora
mi chiesero una sponsorizzazione.
Io lì per lì dissi: "Ma no,
non sono interessato".
E poi: "Mah, quasi quasi,
far qualcosa per la città -"
Perché allora non era come oggi,
che c'è il basket, c'è il calcio a cinque.
Allora c'era solo il calcio,
era un calcio un po' -
era in Serie C2 insomma.
E dissi: "Va bene, quasi quasi mi butto".
Ma più per fare qualcosa per la città,
non pensando assolutamente
che sarebbe diventato
quello che è diventato,
con questo entusiasmo.
Comunque, partiamo
col primo anno di Serie C,
si crea un entusiasmo fantastico
perché la squadra poi andava bene.
Io naturalmente mai avrei pensato
di superare e di andare subito in serie B.
Anche perché erano 35 anni
che non ci si andava.
Qui c'è una bellissima foto dello stadio,
per dire l'entusiasmo,
perché cosa si era creato?
Si era creata una fusione
tra la città, i tifosi, i giocatori -
si parlava solo di questo Mantova.
E da lì si arrivò
a questa benedetta Serie B,
che era 35 anni che non si andava in B.
Per cui per Mantova era un evento.
Prima noi - ecco, questa è una foto
che a me è particolarmente cara,
guardate lo stadio che era veramente,
in gergo si dice "bombato",
perché era quasi una bomboniera.
E appena andata in B,
molti tifosi, soprattutto qualche ultrà,
mi chiese subito "Andiamo in A?"
"Ma che andiamo in A:
è 35 anni che non stiamo in B,
rimaniamo almeno in B, no?"
"Sì, si va bene, va bene."
C'era un po' la paura, nei giocatori,
perché era un'altra categoria,
erano altri giocatori,
c'erano altre squadre importanti,
tipo l'Atalanta, che adesso vedete
cosa sta facendo in serie A, incredibile.
Il Torino - faccio fatica
a dirlo: Torino, vabbè.
E poi c'era il Catania,
c'erano un sacco di squadre blasonate.
Noi, in fin dei conti -
Mantova era una piccola città,
aveva 48 mila persone,
in confronto a Torino, Bergamo, Bologna.
E insomma partiamo
come dei razzi, arriviamo -
io mi ricordo la prima partita
che abbiamo perso,
e magari qualche mantovano
se la ricorderà:
è stato in dicembre,
l'ultima di campionato,
contro il Pescara,
battendo tutte le varie -
E questa è la classifica della Serie B
del girone di andata,
cioè il girone invernale.
C'era: Mantova 42, Catania 40,
questo non riesco a dirlo, Atalanta 38.
Ma incredibile!
Infatti arriva la chiamata di Sky.
Guardate bene: mi chiama Sky,
il direttore, di cui ora
non ricordo [il nome],
è passato tanto tempo, non mi ricordo.
Mi fa: Fabrizio, ci dobbiamo incontrare,
perché dobbiamo firmare
il contratto per la serie A.
Io: per carità, aspettiamo un attimo
perché è ancora presto.
No, mi fa, perché guarda:
non è mai successo
che una squadra che è arrivata,
nel girone di andata, prima in classifica,
non sia andata in Serie A.
Ecco, non era mai successo fino allora,
e infatti io ho toccato ferro.
Cosa è successo?
Siamo rimasti in serie B, purtroppo.
E non è più successo neanche dopo,
negli 80 anni, 90 anni di serie B.
L'unica volta che una squadra
arriva prima nel girone di andata,
[e poi] rimane in serie B.
Qual è stata la squadra? Il Mantova.
Vabbè, non importa.
Ecco, qui facciamo i playoff.
Che molti mantovani,
secondo me, se li ricordano.
Io me li ricordo come se fosse ieri.
Giochiamo contro il Modena,
grande partita, andata e ritorno,
andiamo in finale col Torino
e giochiamo la prima in casa,
vinciamo 4 a 2.
Siamo già vicino al sogno,
quel sogno che io, sinceramente,
non avrei mai sperato
che potesse succedere.
Però stava succedendo.
Fatalità, cosa succede?
Che quella settimana lì,
dopo il quattro a due
che abbiamo giocato in casa -
forse la più bella partita
che ho visto giocare
dal mio Mantova, diciamo.
Avessimo avuto il Real Madrid,
avremmo vinto anche contro il Real Madrid.
Comunque, giochiamo benissimo.
Esce sulla Gazzetta un titolone:
"Scandalo scommesse: Calciopoli"
Praticamente, la Juventus
retrocede in Serie B.
Io dico: no, non è possibile.
Noi andiamo lì a Torino,
facciamo questa partita,
diciamo tra virgolette "onesta",
ma non è una partita -
era una partita che già sulla carta
aveva qualcosa che non andava.
Perché Mantova era una piccola città.
Juve e Toro non potevano rimanere
in serie B, o andare in serie B,
a scapito di un Mantova in serie A.
Per cui la partita
fu a dir poco scandalosa,
un arbitraggio -
posso dire improbabile,
per essere gentile?
e lì si rimase in serie B.
Purtroppo, grandissima delusione:
perché sarebbe stata una favola,
e sarebbe stato il bene
anche per il calcio italiano,
questa favola di questa piccola società
che parte dalla C2
e in tre anni va in serie A.
Vabbè, comunque è andata così.
Il giorno dopo, ricordo la tristezza
infinita, io piansi, mi ricordo.
Al Delle Alpi piansi,
come la maggior parte
dei tifosi del Mantova.
Perché, sapete,
non è facile poi ripetersi.
Comunque, poi, secondo anno di B:
abbiamo Juventus, Napoli e Genova,
cioè le squadrette della parrocchia, no?
E vabbè, in settembre
vado al calciomercato -
perché c'è il calciomercato -
e dico:
"Vediamo qualche giocatore
per potenziare la squadra
perché, in fin dei conti,
la squadra era arrivata:
noi ci siamo andati, in serie A,
ma poi non ci hanno permesso di andare.
Però adesso non sono qui
per dire cose che poi -
Vabbè.
Incontro un giornalista, sempre di Sky.
Perché, si vede che -
E mi dice: "Ma Presidente,
non prenda nessuno quest'anno".
E io dico: "Perché
non devo prendere nessuno?
Scusi, siamo arrivati
in finale, in serie B.
Io ci tengo, a provare ancora
ad andare in serie A"
"Ma no, guardi:
quest'anno non spenda niente,
perché tanto andranno in serie A
la Juventus, il Napoli, e il Genoa.
E probabilmente non si faranno
neanche i playoff".
Ma non diciamo -
Oh, è successo così!
Prima volta nella storia del calcio
che Juve, Napoli e Genoa vanno in serie A.
Noi siamo arrivati quarti o quinti,
abbiamo fatto un campionato eccezionale.
Però, una cosa siamo riusciti a farla.
E adesso, vi voglio far vedere cosa.
Prego, video.
[MANTOVA - JUVENTUS 1-0]
[10 anni fa, la storica
vittoria al Martelli]
[13 gennaio del 2007]
[PICCOLO MA FIERO -
Il trionfo dell'orgoglio biancorosso]
[Anche per i giocatori biancorossi,
è il giorno del sogno che diventa realtà,]
[in campo contro i loro idoli da ragazzi]
[Una partita da vedere e rivedere]
[Il mito Buffon,
fresco campione del mondo,]
[che esce infortunato
tra gli applausi di tutto lo stadio]
[L'errore in extremis di Del Piero]
[La storia è scritta: Juve ko,
dopo 45 partite in Serie A]
[Che festa!]
[Da non dimenticare]
[Il presidente Lori, oggi:
"Fu il punto più alto della mia gestione"]
(Applausi)
Grazie.
Non so se fu il punto
più alto della mia gestione.
Fu diciamo una grande
soddisfazione, questa vittoria.
Ma questa vittoria ha dimostrato -
era due anni che non perdeva, la Juve!
C'erano tutti i campioni del mondo
dei campionati mondiali,
per cui c'era Trezeguet,
che se anche giocava nella Francia,
giocava nella Juventus;
Del Piero - insomma, tutti.
E abbiamo dato dimostrazione,
soprattutto alla Lega,
che noi eravamo una squadra da serie A.
Questo è stato -
per questo i ragazzi
ci hanno messo il cuore,
e abbiamo vinto questa partita.
Poi sono passati anni, diciamo,
abbastanza tranquilli,
ho fatto altri tre anni di serie B,
che già, voglio dire, cinque anni di B
non è poco per una città come Mantova.
Poi nel 2010 ci fu un particolare un po' -
avevamo una buonissima squadra,
però non capivamo.
Io mi ricordo,
allora c'era l'allenatore Serena,
che magari qualcuno si ricorda,
che ci mettevamo a tavolino e dicevamo:
"Ma come mai non riusciamo
a vincere una partita?
Non si capisce, non si capisce."
Insomma il finale della favola,
retrocediamo perché arriviamo penultimi,
retrocediamo, non capendo.
Poi lì c'è stato un capitolo,
c'è stato un fallimento,
c'è stato un capitolo, diciamo,
abbastanza brutto della mia vita
oltre a questa delusione.
Poi, dopo due anni, si venne a sapere
che noi eravamo falliti
perché avevamo dei giocatori
che ci vendevano le partite.
E lì è stata la più grossa
delusione della mia vita,
perché quando ti senti,
tra virgolette, "tradito" -
Cerchi di fare il più possibile,
e poi hai qualche - uno o due giocatori
che tradiscono la tua fiducia...
Forse qualcuno può capire
cosa ho provato in quel momento.
Infatti, per alcuni anni,
non voluto avere niente
a che fare con il calcio
perché ero, tra virgolette,
non so se si può dire, schifato.
E forse è dir poco, schifato.
Ero nauseato da tutto questo mondo,
perché è un mondo un po' così.
Poi insomma, dopo qualche anno
mi è un po' passata,
e ho deciso con la mia compagna,
che saluto - Ciao Elena -
di fare questa piccola accademia
di calcio dilettantistico
con i bambini dai 4 ai 12 anni,
per insegnare loro -
queste sono le foto dei bambini -
insegnare, più che a diventare campioni,
insegnare a vivere e a divertirsi,
perché il calcio deve
essere un divertimento.
Se inizia a diventare - se uno pensa:
"Vado, faccio il calciatore
perché così guadagno milioni di euro"
allora è meglio non farlo.
E fiore all'occhiello,
oltre a questa piccola accademia,
con AS Diverso,
che è una società qui
di Mantova di disabili,
abbiamo fatto una fusione
e abbiamo creato questo -
questa è una squadra favolosa.
Questa squadra si chiama
Accademia Fabrizio Lori - AS Diverso.
E quest'anno, per la prima volta,
abbiamo fatto la serie B a Milano.
Noi naturalmente siamo una piccola realtà,
e ci siamo scontrati contro realtà
come ad esempio Inter, Genova, Fiorentina
che sono tutte affiliate
alle squadre professionistiche.
Noi - questa accademia Fabrizio Lori
è affiliata alla mia Accademia
per cui, per dirvi,
noi andavamo coi pulmini:
io ne guidavo uno,
e Riccardo guidava l'altro.
Loro invece arrivavano coi pullman
della società dell'Inter.
Oh, abbiamo fatto
un campionato eccezionale.
Mi venivano i brividi,
perché mi veniva in mente
il mio Mantova di allora.
Abbiamo battuto l'Inter,
il Genoa, Fiorentina,
insomma praticamente
siamo arrivati terzi in classifica.
Sapete in quanti vanno su?
Due.
(Risate)
Vabbè, non importa,
perché abbiamo ricevuto
il premio più bello
che un Presidente potesse ricevere.
Questo è il premio "Fair Play."
C'erano 45 squadre, l'hanno dato a noi.
Forse perché gli abbiamo
fatto pena, non lo so.
Però probabilmente,
penso che ci daranno il diritto,
me l'hanno già detto,
ma non c'è ancora l'ufficialità,
perché, praticamente,
prima, seconda, terza,
poi c'era la quarta che aveva
un divario di punti impensabile.
Per cui secondo me ci faranno andare -
perché io, prima o poi,
in questa A ci voglio andare, scusate.
E comunque è un altro modo
di vedere le cose,
però mi han dato
delle gioie, questi ragazzi.
Io li chiamo ragazzi speciali,
perché per me sono veramente speciali.
Anzi, vi dirò di più.
Ho imparato molto di più io da loro,
in questo ultimo anno,
che loro da me.
Perché mi hanno dato un senso
di leggerezza, e di felicità,
che erano tanti anni che non provavo.
Io vi ringrazio,
spero di non avervi annoiato
e vi ringrazio di avermi ascoltato.
Grazie.
(Applausi)